the challenge is the United States faces
right now are greater than at any other
time in my lifetime and probably
comparable to what we faced in the 1930s
where you had an economic crisis but you
also had numerous possible security
crises around the world and those were
both driven by ideology in those days
Marxism fascism communism and but also
great power rivalries so today we've got
traditional problems so Russia invades
Georgia that's pretty traditional
politics where you've got to deter other
powers from using military force you've
also got to ensure with the rise of
China and India that the system stays
stable because you don't have to think
China and India are threats I don't but
if you look at your history when new
powers rise old powers often get nervous
the good good part of that story is when
the United States Rose Great Britain was
able to move over the bad part of that
story is that when Germany rose we had
World War one and then World War two so
you still got all these traditional
issues and you have to look out for
those but then you have an entirely new
set of problems first non-state actors
so we're the first generation ever where
individuals can do the kind of damage
that only states could do before if a
terrorist group got hold of a nuclear
weapon they would be able to do more
damage than any major attack by any
state unless it were all out nuclear
attack so that's a whole new set of
problems and it's not just terrorists we
always focus on terrorists but actually
their global criminal networks of money
launderers and arms traffickers and drug
traffickers often that can be connected
to terrorist groups but also trafficking
in women and children which is a rising
phenomenon that is in many ways like the
slavery of
our time and then finally you have the
problems of Mother Nature herself so
climate change is obviously the one we
we are thinking about most but I always
tell people that when i wake up at four
in for them i always tell people when i
wake up at four in the morning and worry
about what could kill my kids I'm
actually more worried about bird flu
global epidemics are a very real threat
so you've got traditional state to state
threats non-state actors and mother
nature makes for a very complicated
picture